welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and as of filming
the early reviews for Dwayne's hierarchy
shaking passion project are all saying
that Pierce Brosnan as Dr Fate is the
highlight of the film so today I want to
break down both Kent Nelson's and
naboo's comic history and speculate on
what the introduction of Dr Fate means
for the future of the dceu thanks to
thrive market for sponsoring this video
more on them in just a minute before we
start this video is mostly spoiler free
for Black Adam towards the very end I'll
include a spoiler warning so that you
can dip out if you haven't seen it yet
if you leave a comment on this video
with a spoiler be sure to tag it out of
respect for your fellow nerds now let's
get into fate Dr Fate first appeared in
more fun Comics number 55 in 1940 just
two years after Superman's comic debut
and one year before Batman making this
character one of the OG Heroes of DC and
although it features a lot of
similarities with Marvel's doctor
strange and Moon Knight actually
predates Steven by about 20 years and
marked by 35. Dr Fate is a bit like
Shazam in the sense that he's the Avatar
of a mortal who can magically Suit Up by
being a conduit to divine power the
major difference is that when The
Mortals put on the Helm of Fate they're
essentially puppets to a Godly Lord of
order Naboo no relation to padme's
Homeworld this dude is from the ancient
Planet cilia despite being on team good
guy Naboo is a bit of an a-hole and
doesn't exactly care about the
well-being and desires of his hosts just
stopping agents of chaos the longer a
person serves Dr Fate the more of their
personal past becomes a hazy memory
because nemu's powers are tied to the
Helm of Fate there have been several
hosts who have become Dr Fate sometimes
even with multiple hosts fusing into one
being sometimes it's a stepson with a
stepmother but that's a Freudian not to
entangle for another time you ever watch
behind the scenes featurettes on how
crazy healthy actors have to be and
start to think to yourself well sure if
I had a staff of nutritionists and chefs
I'd be healthy too good news Ian healthy
just got a whole lot easier thanks to
thrive Market Thrive Market is an online
membership-based grocery store on a
mission to make healthy living easy and
affordable for everyone because look
let's be honest unless you live next
door to a health food store you're
probably not stocking up on chia seeds
and kale chips on the rag no matter how
vegan keto low carbon impact you're
trying to eat Thrive sends products you
choose to your door making eating
healthy easier than ever Thrive Market
can also help you cut your grocery bill
by over 30 percent you can shop for
thousands of the best-selling organic
foods and natural products below
traditional retail prices at the newer
exeter's office we've been tossing back
these grass-fed beef sticks from Chomps
and these organic fruit snacks into our
moths and boy do we love it salty beef
sticks right little fruit snacks we eat
them we love them it's fun click the
link in the description box or go to
thrivemarket.com new rockstars to
receive a free 60 gift when you join
Thrive market today the most prominent
Dr Fate host and the one Brosnan plays
in Black Adam is Kent Nelson in more fun
Comics number 67 we get Nelson's origin
story and this story set in 1920 we meet
a young Kent the Swedish American son of
an archaeologist named Sven Nelson
Savannah is basically an ancient aliens
truther he believes that there's no way
man could have built the pyramids alone
and decides to venture to Egypt with his
son to unearth the truth he brings Kent
along with him to explore an underground
pyramid the two find evidence of an
alien language written on the walls of
the Tomb Kent being a kid wanders off to
explore while his dad does boring
Indiana Jones steps and stumbles upon an
ancient Immortal being known as Naboo
Naboo and sorcel's Kent's mind and
influences him to pull a lever that
releases the god along with a poisonous
gas that kills Sven Naboo is like yeesh
sorry about that kid how about I teach
you the secrets of the universe to cheer
you up Kent takes him up on it and with
naboo's tutelage he becomes Dr Fate
after receiving Divine empowerment
Fate's powers are nearly Limitless due
to the helmet of Fate The Amulet of
Anubis and the cloak of Destiny in
addition to the usual lineup of
superhuman strength levitation
electrokinesis illusion casting and
invulnerability he's also able to
convert energy into matter and matter
into energy he can telepathically
influence any being or object phase
through walls astral project and perform
a number of occult rituals and spells
fate is one one of the most powerful
Sorcerers in the universe and although
he most often uses his powers for good
he sometimes struggles to accept his
abilities as both a gift and a curse
even without naboo's power Kent becomes
a masterful sorcerer on his own to tap
it off this dude is also a doctor an
archaeologist a martial artist and can
speak multiple languages okay show off
I'm pretty sure that's the exact career
my mom hoped I'd have before I
disappointed her by becoming a comedian
but it also gets access to a secret base
the Tower of Fate an invisibility
cloaked Tower in Salem Massachusetts
that houses numerous magical artifacts
of power as Ken adventured through the
comics naboo's voice guided fate as he
fought on behalf of the Lords of order
against the Lords of chaos while
traveling through Alexandria Kent meets
a young woman named inza the two fall in
love together they fought Supernatural
entities in more fun Comics defeating a
gallery of villains beginning with an
evil sorcerer called Wilton in their
first issue a cool 30 issues later
saving the world with his dope
girlfriend all the time just wasn't
enough so he enrolled in medical school
during World War One Dr Fate and several
other Heroes including Adam The Flash
Specter Green Lantern Hawkman Sandman
and our man were persuaded by President
Roosevelt to form the Justice Society of
America after Adam saved his life fate
inspector also managed to close a portal
to the demon realm during this time
defeating the elder god koth shukoff the
god of wrath's powers at one point in
the early 40s to curb naboo's invasive
control over his body Kent made himself
a half helmet replica of the Helm of
fate and instead drew his powers from
The Amulet of Anubis and the cloak of
Destiny back in 2030 BC Anubis granted
Kelis an evil priest his most prized
artifact and he used it to enslave the
people of Egypt for many years
thankfully Naboo thought that this was
[ __ ] so he confiscated The Amulet
and turned kalis into a mummy one of the
cooler aspects of this particular
artifact is that it has its own pocket
Universe it's also revealed later to
trap The Souls of Fallen Dr Fate hosts
in 1942's All-Star Squadron number 23
Kent went back to wearing the helm
estate to revert to his full power in an
attempt to find his missing JSA teammate
Specter not long after the Helm of Fate
was lost when it and the evil priest
kulak were thrown into Infinite
Dimensions between this point and the
60s Kent would use his half-helmed
Persona sparingly eventually retiring
from crime fighting at some point during
this period Kent was reunited with the
Helm of Fate off page and was wearing it
again when DC dusted him offers in
publication return to 1963's Justice
League of America number 21. in the 80s
Ken's relationship with Naboo interfered
with his marriage to inza and naboo's
enemies the Lords of chaos would use
this to their advantage to manipulate
enza into breaking Kent's heart in a bid
to retain his power to build and boob
an event to retain his power Naboo
absorbed inza into the Dr Fate Persona
against her wishes this was the first of
many fusions we'd see of Dr Fate Kent
would go on to team up with the Justice
League for a spell until 87 when a four
issue solo run would turn the Helm of
Fate over to Eric and Linda Strauss the
aforementioned loyal son and the mom who
stepped up in this Arc a war between the
higher beings of ordering chaos entered
a stage known as Kali Yuga Yuga aka the
final age of man had the Lords of order
pull out from battling the Lords of
Chaos in the hopes that chaos would
destroy itself an order could create a
golden age in its way this stream the
magic keeping Kent and enza Youthful and
Enzo began to rapidly age inza died and
before Kent was allowed to die himself
Naboo had him seek out a new host for Dr
Fate Kent and enza lived their entire
afterlife within the Amulet of Anubis
until the 90s when Naboo decided to
resurrect them into younger bodies Enzo
would be the primary doctor fate persona
for a stint before the writers reverted
them back into a fused Persona in 97 and
it ends as Dr Fate died to make way for
fate hold the doctor the spitting image
of comics in the 90s Fate's run was
brief however fast forwarding past DC's
retconning of their Multiverse because
Comics the modern version of Kent Nelson
is now alive and well and shares the
title and powers of Naboo with his great
nephew Khalid nassor Khalid is the
primary host of Dr Fate but his mentor
Kent's extensive past with Naboo allows
for him to tap into a portion and abu's
power which brings me to the DCU here's
your spoiler warning y'all click out now
if you haven't seen seen Black Adam for
those of you that are staying here's the
deal I won't get a chance to see Black
Adam until tonight so I'm unfortunately
only working off trailers promo footage
interviews and prayers that said I'm
pretty sure that I've got enough details
to start theorizing so I've heard that
despite his commanding performance it
gave Pierce Brosnan the old Ben Kenobi
treatment in this film for all the Fate
fans out there I don't think that this
will be the last we see of fate or even
Ken Nelson however though this is
probably the last time we'll be seeing
Nelson as a living breathing person I'd
imagine that if the dceu wants to keep
the title of Dr Fate around for the next
era of films they'll start transitioning
to another holder of the Doctor Fate
title personally my vote is for the DC
amu's original character steel Maxim
this himbo is the perfect contrast to
the self-serious Naboo and I think be an
interesting Dynamic to explore further
I'm joking although I do love steel
Maxim stripper Fates more Harley Quinn
animated series material we're probably
going to get a version of khalidnosaurs
the next fate as the younger Dr Fate we
could see khalid's struggle with naboo's
manipulations more prominently as he
doesn't have years of training and
experience Kent has through either the
Amulet of Anubis or the helmet fade
itself Kent can still play a mentor role
to Khalid as a ghostly psychic presence
and as we've seen death really hasn't
stopped Naboo from resurrecting Kent
I've also seen some speculation that
Adriana's son Eamon might take on
khalid's story for the film franchise
though personally I think that DC should
stick to the source material and go with
caledosaur because if you're going off
book you already know my vote why not me
six percent body fat 20-inch guns hell I
even took a magic class once thanks
again the Thrive market for sponsoring
this video don't forget to click the
link in the description to receive a
free 60 gift when you join Thrive market
today follow me on Instagram and Twitter
whitneypuppy follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]